no one I guess should intentionally
inflict trauma on their children
although I feel like we can bring back
hitting kids the kids I see I'm like he
just needs one like do you ever meet
someone that you're like the only thing
holding the back in life is just getting
hit like once why do people always think
that like that's gonna stop it the
biggest are the ones that have
gotten punched in the face and then have
realized it ain't that bad it's this
idea like oh we just need to punch and
then everybody goes all right I guess we
should stop World War one and World War
II happen yeah the Germans didn't learn
a lesson it's the dumbest idea I've ever
heard